[Music]
hmm
[Music]
stack versus heat grasping the
difference between these two types of
memory storage
make the difference between your program
crashing and
[Music]
all right well let's get into what are
the differences you actually need to
know
if you're a programmer or if you're just
interested in coding how memory works
this might be interesting
[Music]
what is a stack a stack is a special
area of a computer's memory which stores
temporary variables created by a
function
in stack variables are declared stored
and initialized
during run time it is a temporary
storage memory
when a computing task is complete the
memory of the variable will be
automatically erased
stack section mostly contains methods
local variables and
reference variables the heap is memory
storage
used by programming languages to store
global variables
by default all global variables are
stored in heap memory that supports
dynamic
memory allocation the heap is not
managed automatically for you nor is it
tightly managed by the cpu is more
like a free floating region of memory so
keep those in mind global variables free
floating region
not managed so far you can probably
already figure out that this spells
fragmentation which is the drawback
alright so here we have a nice little
outline of the key differences
key difference stack is a linear data
structure okay so in this way you can
think of a stack as a literal stack like
a stack of papers
stack of cards a stack of whatever a
literal stack
so when you want to get to stuff in the
stack you can't just grab
something out of the middle because it
will no longer be linear if you delete
something out of the middle it's
it's uh it's gonna smash or stack smash
so the memory is gonna move basically if
you pull something out of the middle
it's uh
a little risky because of that as you
can as you might know already
pointers are just a reference to a piece
of memory so if you're referencing
something in stack
and something else moves and shifts all
the others and
all the the memory addresses change you
run into a weird problem all right i'm
getting ahead of this
uh let's keep reading whereas a st a
heap of steep
a heap is a hierarchical data structure
why is that word so hard to say
stack memory will never become
fragmented because it's linear right
whereas heap memory can become
fragmented
as blocks of memory are allocated and
then free so as things become
allocated and freed it doesn't just
magically shift things
around to make them efficient dak
accesses local
variables well heap allows you to access
variables globally okay we already kind
of talked about that
stack local stuff at program runtime
inside functions usually
just temporary usually uh and he mean
things you declare that you always want
to have access this will be like
just anything throughout the program
that you always need to have access to
like your main
things like maybe your main fields for
what your program does
all right stack variables can't be
resized whereas heat variables can
be resized now that's kind of important
too the whole reason that can't be
resized is
it would break the linear data structure
everything else you
would have to be moved if you resize one
thing now everything else in the stack
has to become
shifted to a different piece of memory
and it's it's bad it's real messy so
you just don't do it basically but in
theory you could it's just
real messy whereas heap variables can be
resized that's because they're within
these fragmented blocks or your
free memory in general so it kind of
makes sense that you can just
copy around to a new space that has
enough and or just allocate it
fragmented somewhere else whatever you
need
it's a lot of freedom there stack memory
is allocated in a contiguous block which
should make sense whereas heap is
allocated in random order yep
so it's not necessarily random but
generally there's some algorithm it
follows to use the next free space that
makes sense
so it's more like heuristically curated
doesn't require
to deallocate variables so yeah these
will usually get
destroyed and destructors whereas heap
deallocation is needed stack allocation
and
deallocation are done by compiler
instructions whereas heap allocation and
de-application is done by the program
okay stack is linear
a heap is hierarchical stack has
high access speed and heap is slower and
you can imagine this because
in a heap you gotta skip over memory you
gotta
go through fragmentations basically
whereas a stack you can just
fly through the memory one at a time
until you get to what you need so it's
always linear access
speed as far as uh data complexity
space management space managed
efficiently by the os
so memory is never fragmented uh heap
space is
not used sufficiently memory can become
fragmented first allocated than free
okay access
local variables only heap access allows
access to variables globally
limit space a limit of the stack size is
dependent on the os
does not have a specific limit on memory
size the allocation de-allocation
stack is automatic by compiling
instructions heaps manually done
explicit de-allocation needed for heap
okay
stack is cheaper declaring globally on
the heap is more expensive so that's
pretty important okay the implementation
this is where it's going to get
a little more critical for us as
programmers a stack can be
implemented in three ways let's change
gears a little bit
so in practice
stack and heap is a little more
complicated
because you have to take into account
things like
your compiler and the optimizations it's
trying to do
okay so i try to ask the question does a
vector
use the stack or heap because initially
when i looked at it i wasn't sure
i found an answer to that on quora we're
going to read it here
does standard factor use stack or heap
memory why
and the top answer and i'll just read it
here
each non-empty standard vector uses two
separate contiguous memory regions
one has a fixed size and holds three
pointers
or equivalent and the allocator
the other has a variable size and holds
the object stored in the vector and
optionally some extra uninitialized
space
they can both be on the stack heap
static
shared mapped or any other kind of
memory
available to the program by default
no allocator was provided and the
operator new was not replaced
and heap allocation was not moved to
stack by the optimizer
the variable length chunk is on the heap
as noted in other answers
and the fixed size chunk is wherever the
vector
object was created i imagine this is all
most people will be able to take on the
subject but there's a lot of info out
there
if you find any awesome resources feel
free to either share them here or in
discord where we do have a channel
just put them in like the computer
science discussion or something all
right
i'll see you guys later peace out
[Music]
you